we didn't just land on the earth from
somewhere we came out of the earth so
you know we're all coming from this kind
of same place plants and people and if
you look at indigenous cultures so
people who kind of are endemic to their
place who still live where their
ancestors live and they have that
knowledge you see that plants are
integral to their lives and you might be
thinking like food or medicine but also
like musical instruments and housing and
anything you know the baskets that they
carry everything in all that their
clothing it all comes from plants and
that ethnobotany covers all of that yeah
and sometimes the term economic botany
is used to just talk about how people
use plants economically and any
classification what I think for what I'm
doing now at Harvard MIT the most
interesting things are looking at that
indigenous knowledge and thinking about
how it might be applicable to the things
that we're doing now what can we learn
from indigenous people boom what's up
everyone welcome to simulation I'm your
host on sockin we are at the Harvard
Science Center at Harvard in Cambridge
Massachusetts
we are now going to be talking about f
no botany we have dr. John de Labarre
joining us on the show hello hey nice to
meet you thank you so much for coming on
I'm really excited to talk to you really
appreciate Alex Kate Shen making the
bumps for us to connect and make this
happen dr. John della par is an
associate at Harvard University is a
research lead at the open agriculture
initiative at MIT Media Lab he's a
lecturer of Environmental Studies at
Tufts University and a lecturer of
biotechnology at Northeastern University
all right John let's start things off
with our favorite question here we'd
love to start off with we find ourselves
as stewards of Earth what is your
current take on the state of humanity a
state of humanity so as you mentioned my
expertise is ethnobotany so I'm looking
always at how humans and plants are
interacting plants in a lot of ways are
kind of a true crystal ation of life on
Earth because they can't run away from
things they have to live where they are
you know they have to that that actually
advantage of not having to run away
means that they do very interesting
things humans I think that what happens
in the questions about the state of
humanity
humans have the ability to in some ways
overpopulate their spaces yeah so I
think that one of the most pressing
issues in this for the state of humanity
is is overpopulation I think that that's
something that in certain areas is
causing fights over resources and things
like that so I think that we're at a
beautiful place now where we have an
opportunity to start thinking about how
we use those resources that could be the
plants or other things plants are always
integral to that but as we educate each
other and as we are able to speak about
all these different interconnections
between plants and people that's when we
can make that next leap forward I think
so
even though yet I believe that there is
this crisis of population that's
happening I think that we have the
solutions before us I think that it's
through education that deep education to
young people all the way through to
older people can lead to like I said a
great leap forward that really changes
things
he's a hopeful I guess yeah yeah yeah
yeah and it was also very interesting
you you know you're making the case but
the crystallization of the plants in the
location that they're set in versus the
human and animal the marine animals as
well just being able to move around the
other really interesting thing that that
you said was that you're so right that
we have in many places these centers
that are filled with clusters of people
and I think what we ended up doing was
in many ways we want to surround
ourselves with other
smart diverse people in close proximity
so we don't have to transit too far but
at the same time it has made for so much
issues with with like you said fighting
over resources rent in many places is
very expensive slums exist at versus
these open swathes of land around the
world that are just free for people to
live on basically right so there's a
there's that interesting dichotomy that
you brought up as well yeah I mean and
swaths of land are usually not free for
people to live on in general I mean we
might there there there's more space
right I just you know we as humans have
evolved to in in in some ways small
groups with family members extended
family and also relying on the sources
that are around us we did always have
the ability to move around but in some
ways I think cities recall that wanting
to have community and people try to
reconstitute that that desire for
community everywhere we go but often so
that you know I live in a city even
though I grew up on a farm I grew up in
a rural area and I find community in a
city it's a different type of thing but
often it can be more profound because
you know you are up against each other
and you do have to figure out how to
share with the space that you have
around you and plants mediate by
interaction I think in many ways yeah
yeah we're gonna get to that I'm super
pumped to unpack that let's do your
journey so born in Alabama and then you
had a very you have some roots from
Mexico and then you had a grandmother
that really inspired you to have no body
yes to teach us about this yes so yeah I
grew up on a small farm in Alabama
mostly we had goats when I was a kid and
we also grew a lot of the food that we
ate so we did rely on the farm a lot my
parents still are on that farm and they
still grow a lot they still grow food
every year they still have I think one
go at left now but that's those are my
roots for sure my grandmother used
plants as a
kid and that always fascinated me so
there was always this kind of folk
knowledge there was just almost
spiritual connection that I maybe didn't
realize because when you're a child you
know like the fish doesn't notice the
water around it and I didn't know what
that was but it just was what life was
and that always intrigued me to look
more into it and it definitely
reverberate it later in life yeah my
father's family has roots in Mexico so
you know in my last name as Spanish I
mean being that a little bit separate
from the other Alabama Society you know
other people in society I think
sometimes you find people come up with
interesting lives because they've been
isolated I think a little bit so you
know being an Alabama being a little
different I think made me more
introspective want to do something a
little bit different which eventually
led me I so my last two years of high
school I was in a rural place in the
Appalachian Mountains and but my last
two years I went to a boarding school in
Alabama state-funded boarding school the
album school of math and science and if
it weren't for that I don't know what I
would have done luckily the state had
this vision to fund this project and
they about a hundred students from
around the state were allowed to come
and my parents had no money but this but
it was paid for by the state
so it was an amazing resource for me and
there I met my fellow we were travelers
you know kids from all around Alabama
who didn't quite fit into the schools
that they're in but now they could be
here and really kind of nerd out yeah
and also it was a very college like
atmosphere that was somewhat
unstructured in that you know there were
labs on Tuesdays and Thursdays and you
know we kind of had to figure out how to
manage your time then from there I went
to the Cooper Union which is in New York
City an engineering art and architecture
school I had never been to New York City
before so I was totally Alabama when I
showed up in New York I think that I
know the first time I went to New York
was for the orientation for Cooper Union
on top of it being New York City which
is can be overwhelming for anyone
and it's kind of the prototypical city
you know if we're talking about rural
versus city it was also a very intense
educational system so I was studying
engineering and it was kind of like a
bootcamp mentality I mean your first
year everyone takes very difficult
standardized classes that you know there
might be a giant electric halls and
there has to be a bell curve
reinstituted over top of even the
brightest people that show up so that
was really intense for me and I was
always looking for nature I remember
going to Central Park and taking my
socks and shoes off just so I could feel
the grass you know and be connected to
earth which seems like a somewhat
trivial thing but for me it actually was
really meaningful we have some
connection or to take you know even a
day or two trip out to visit someone at
Vassar which is in pick up see a little
bit farther off though you know I could
see trees and be out in the woods a
little bit yes I that is what I think
where I discovered that some dichotomy
of existence that you know there is this
thing I knew as a kid in Alabama then
there's the city and you have to kind of
balance those things in some ways yeah
you totally nail it there was farm
versus Manhattan right yeah those are
vast different extremes
yes dreams and your if we if we can get
a deeper sense of connection to earth by
doing things like just laying on the
grass taking your shoes oh yeah just
relaxing feeling earth the trees the
plants we can really tie better into
that unity feeling that that drives us
that will drive us to a more sustainable
future okay so as you're you know as
you're getting getting new york you feel
that dichotomy you also end up doing
your PhD at Northeastern here in Boston
yeah and that journey was rather long
and circuitous so it wasn't a direct
route for me at all I mentioned this
kind of pressure cooker situation of all
my family being in Alabama me being in
New York City a very foreign bizarre
place for me the first year I was there
I don't think I got on the subway once
because I was just afraid of everything
you know I was 18 I didn't know what was
safe and what wasn't it was
overwhelming eventually after a few
years I was totally relaxed there but
and now it feels like a second home to
me because I had to in some ways become
a man in this environment so you know
that there was that a pool that tension
in my life and then I was studying
engineering which was never exactly
something I wanted but Cooper Union if
you get in it's free to go and my
parents like I said they couldn't afford
to send me to school so it was the
obvious choice for me it was a good
school and it was free but by the time I
had reached the fourth year is actually
2001 2002 in New York City so September
11th happened freaking out oh I didn't
Cooper name is in lower Manhattan oh
it's in Lorman
yeah so yeah and I at one point lived on
Gould Street which is in the financial
district so it was disturbing to me
because I had just become kind of
comfortable in this place and now it
seemed scary to me again I mean it was
very disruptive and being in LA my head
and like that part of the city was shut
down for part of the couple few weeks
just in terms of transportation and so
it was very difficult so I I didn't know
what I was gonna do I didn't want to be
in New York I just want to be in New
York anymore I wound up getting a job in
the New York State Assembly as a
legislative aide and I worked there for
a bit which seems totally weird but
that's what I wanted I wanted something
that was completely different than what
I've been doing before I always had an
interest in politics of all things and I
kind of I've always had this thing in my
life that I want to taste everything I
don't want to try a lot of different
things and I even tell my students now
that sometimes it's about finding out
what you don't like not what you do like
and I've done a lot of that and that's
when that started so I did that I still
hadn't finished Cooper so I had just a
handful of credits left to finish but I
I didn't care about it at that point I
just wanted to I wanted to do things I
didn't want to be in school anymore
so in my last year I left and I did this
found out I didn't really like
I eventually moved to New Jersey where I
did other types of things I did some
consulting work I eventually started
taking classes in horticulture and I got
a certified in horticulture because I
wanted to get back to you know I guess
in some ways in response to September
11th in the city I would now want it to
be really into plants and really have
that connection again which symbolizes
in some way where I came from and where
I could go so then I did that I started
studying that and at the same time I
started teaching well I was able to
finish my undergrad in that time and
that took me several years I did that
and then I started teaching at a
community college in New Jersey I
started teaching chemistry and I loved
it I I never thought I'd have the chance
to teach so for me it was really magical
to be in front of students that are
mostly nursing students which you know
it's they have a real mission it's
actually like a tactile thing that
you're going to do and chemistry's users
of the class they want to take the least
so but I saw it as an opportunity to
show them practical things yes because I
also feel like I don't have a lot of
patience for things that don't I can't
understand why you're doing that yeah
correct so when I would teach them
chemistry we would always do things like
I would you know bring an IV bag in and
we talked about ions and like why would
they ever need to know where that ion is
you know if they're not gonna understand
when they see it in a hospital what it
actually means so I always tie things in
the experiments with my favorite part
and I was also of course interested in
plants I had this sort of culture
background and I was starting to get
interested more in teaching people about
medicinal plants I eventually started a
class that was called medicinal plants
so that um a lot of people really like
tonight I was really getting my footing
just in having in some ways taught
myself about the stuff but inspired by
my grandmother and other people in my
life and that gave me an outlet and I
felt like well this is my special thing
that I feel I get up every morning to do
yeah and and then I once I found that I
was like okay like I need to just keep
building on this and that pressure of
having to teach especially something
that you really care about is it's a
weird feeling right it's
you may be like sweating like this
nervous anxiety sweat but also you're
loving what you're doing you get
addicted to it so for me like I like I'm
teaching for classes this semester like
I love it and also like it's like tense
it's like yeah it's like a but you feel
alive I guess that's what it is you're
pushing yourself to the brink of your
cognitive challenge yeah every single
day and it's a performance it's a
high-wire act every time yeah I mean I
know there are people who prepare way
ahead of time and they have their slides
but still even and I don't always have
the time to do that but even when I do
it's still a performance you know you're
still what's gonna happen in the
classroom if you're think you're doing
it right it should be malleable you know
because people are gonna ask questions
oh the conversations gonna go a
different way and literally and that's
how the learning experience really
happens yes and you have to be prepared
for all that yeah so from then I said
well if I want to keep doing this on any
other level beyond the community college
or whatever I need to go to graduate
school so I eventually I found a
professor that I thought was doing
something that pushed the boundary of
chemistry medicinal plants biotech the
future of what could happen with
medicinal plants because actually the
truth is a lot of kids come to me and
say how do I study medicinal plants how
do I become an ethno botanist and the
answer isn't easy you have to be very
determined because there aren't a lot of
there are some really great ethno
botanist mentors in the world and in the
US but not as many as there used to be
and it's not easy to find that track to
do that so the person I found was not
enough no botanist at all but they were
doing something that was interesting to
me so I targeted them I got into the
program and I learned all about plant
tissue culture and different plant
chemicals and things like
loved it but after two years our paths
kind of were diverged and I was going
more in a different direction with
analytical chemistry and looking at
what's in these plants and how can we
vary that chemical constituency of these
plants so eventually finished my PhD and
their different professor but at all it
shows you how like even though you might
have a singular mindset like this is the
person that's kind of driving me to do
this you have to be flexible enough to
know when it's time to change course a
little bit and that really opened up
everything for me once I left that
laboratory and I was able to be free
from that and do other things or more
inventive things got even more exciting
for me even though it was incredibly
scary and after that second year when I
thought I was gonna be all over when I
was gonna leave that lab I thought we'll
walk at a master's degree or who knows
what I'll do maybe I just have to leave
and not finish this at all but that leap
led to greater things which is the thing
that people are always afraid of and
people tell you that right but you never
believe it on the other side of the
adversities is our greatest treasure
I fully believe that I mean the things I
went through from Alabama jumping to New
York of all places and and then jumping
out of New York without a degree
finished
and then jumping back into graduate
school and then out of one lab into
another those have been the things that
really propelled my life in a way that
might have been more boring I guess I
went to the greatest challenges and you
found your greatest treasures yeah I
think I think that's a good way of
putting it yeah that's the journeys so
beautiful and that's what really
stretches you to the brink of your your
abilities and it challenges you the most
and it puts you in a place where you're
learning a lot it's also interesting
that you have this this way of viewing
teaching as something that is very very
valuable you come in there like you said
with a malleability so that the
conversation can move whichever - wait
do
it needs with the students when they're
asking questions and I love how you
found that interest in teaching and
ethnobotany so all right now ethno body
in general is very interesting the plant
and human interaction is interesting the
coevolution is very interesting it's
been you know billions of years of
evolution on the planet millions of
years of human evolution with plants and
we find ourselves now in many ways
finally becoming more and more literate
with understanding some of the
psychoactive properties of plant
medicines we find a lot of the nature
therapy that's going on around the world
or we just walk into force and decreases
their cortisol level all these types of
interesting things
what gardening does for the Soul these
types of things yeah so what have you
been learning about this coevolution
well I mean actually something
understand its I guess what thirty
thousand years of human plant like
cultivation really but and humans
themselves only 100 or more thousand
years that go back with humans and kind
of being in this plant place because
that's what we're in it's a great place
it's a plant place I mean it is I mean
we evolved with them
and and and we all came we didn't just
land on the earth from somewhere we came
out of the earth so you know we're all
coming from this kind of same place
plants and people and if you look at
indigenous cultures so people who kind
of are endemic to their place who still
live where their ancestors lived and
they have that knowledge you see that
plants are integral to their lives I
know and you might be thinking like food
or medicine but also like musical
instruments and housing and anything you
know the baskets that they carry
everything in all that their clothing it
all comes from plants and that
ethnobotany covers all of that yeah and
sometimes the term economic botany as
you
to just talk about how people use plants
economically in any classification what
I think for what I'm doing now at
Harvard MIT the most interesting things
are looking at that indigenous knowledge
and thinking about how it might be
applicable to the things that we're
doing now what can we learn from
indigenous people and for me the
greatest reward has come from thinking
about not just the species that people
choose for a particular purpose let's
say for medicine because people have
known that they've collected plants of
particular species to do particular
things healthful healthful things but
indigenous people don't just choose a
species they choose what we might call
in science world a phenotype so you know
actual expression of the plant and that
phenotype is influenced by the
environment so indigenous people
understand that well I don't just pick
you know this plant because it's this
plant I picked because it's this side of
the mountain at this time of day and
this time of year and this growth stage
and all those other things that go into
making an actual physical plant a
physical plant and what we found is that
those things have a lot of effect on the
chemistry of the plant which is kind of
the fundamental makeup of the plant and
if we're talking about drum discovery or
drum usage of a plant or any type of
medicinal uses or food usage we have to
be aware of what those phenotypes or we
might even call them chemo types so the
chemical type of that plant is because
that is what will give us the true
benefit so you know I'm working on some
projects now we're looking at produce so
all the product when you go to the store
you look at the point of sale where you
actually buy the produce and you may
have heard that let's say apples are
good for you but what what does that
mean an apple is not an apple is not an
apple an apple that was grown at a
certain time of year is gonna have a
different chemical makeup than a apple
that has grown it you know another time
of year or in place or any of these
things will change drastically sometimes
the chemistry and the variables of the
environment that the fruit is grown in
right any soil compositions the
atmospheric compositions episode of the
nutrients of water that it gets yeah so
I'm really you pick it or late you pick
yeah how about you take until you eat it
off right off of if you right off this
probably has more of the nutrient value
than if you wait a month
sure yes yeah that's a good example
also when insects or plants or some
environmental stresses are on a plant
let's say medicinal plant in particular
you can sometimes get more and different
phytochemicals plant chemicals that are
good for for treating a disease I'll say
because often those chemicals that the
plant makes that humans have found as
useful are made not to give the humans a
gift necessarily if they're made to
defend something and defend the plant
because again like I said they can't run
away right so the plant is stuck in
place it has both an active and an
inducible defense system so an active
defense system might be thorns but in a
inducible defense system will be some
kind of metabolic regulation of the
chemistry of the plant so that when a
caterpillar is chewing on at the plant
changes its chemistry and up regulates
the production of something that's gonna
prevent the caterpillar from eating
anymore yes yeah and those same
compounds might be good for stopping
cancer cells from dividing that's a very
interested a so that and then we find in
this crossover a lot and humans have
relied on this medicine in an anecdotal
way for a long time and the reason why
this can be particularly important is
because there's been some disdain in
modern Western medicine for up
herbal medicine or plant-based medicine
because it's so complex so and and
modern medicine is very reductionist so
we like to have one
pound that has one mechanism of action
that treats one disease or condition but
the truth is that plants make thousands
of compounds and they do many different
things in the body at once and those are
admittedly very hard to track in fact we
don't even have a good way to measure
all those compounds in the plant there
are many different tests that it takes
to piece together what you might call
the metabolome
or the entire chemistry of a plant and
it's expensive and labor-intensive so
let's say we figured all the chemistry
now we have to figure well what do they
do when they go in your body and they
might do a hundred different things on
several different organ systems just
working in concert and they might treat
you know you might look in an herbal
book and say well what does this plant
do and it might say ten things that's
very common because there are many
different compounds that do different
things it may be that in the indigenous
knowledge that you had to pick that
plant at a certain time of year certain
type of the plant that it would be
better for this condition or something
that may have been lost the historical
record yes but you know this that that's
helped humans practice medicine for most
of the existence of humans and plants we
were potentially our edge of knowledge
has actually receded a little bit over
the last several thousand years of
Industrial Revolution and Internet age
especially our spiritual knowledge our
plant medicine knowledge in some ways in
some ways of course we've got the
scientific tools to be able to poke
deeper at the chemistry's and what not
but the average person that lives in a
metropolis not only doesn't even get to
see the stars that much but they don't
get to really touch the soil or or
understand the the season of of a plant
medicine and how I can affect their
biology yeah it's it's very foreign to
most modern people I think in the West
at least you know we might use it it was
I mean 80 percent of the world uses
plant based medicine in some way so they
use a crude you know plant based
medicine in some way and we're just
manufacturing molecules here yes but I
mean we do derive some of our we do
derive I think something like sixty
percent of the drugs are in some way
natural derived so that might mean from
an other like a bacteria as well but you
know they're coming from some natural
source and then maybe they're modified
or or something that changes the plant
chemistry in some way to be more
suitable as a drug there isn't so we do
we use those scaffold scaffolds to
create a lot of the drugs that we use
now but most people don't have the
ability to do that I mean they still
have to use the plant in its crude form
or make a simple extract in water or
ethanol or something like that
yeah and we don't understand that it's
kind of a dark space where we don't
fully understand how it's working either
another way that we've talked about this
on the show so many times is that it's
been billions of years of evolution and
we don't actually have a ledger of all
of what has happened in those biological
processes like you said when it
caterpillar it seats at the leaf the
plant figures out a way to survive and
if we could figure out some of the
processes of the you know biochemical
pathways and all the different things
that are actually occurring in there
could we use some of those things to
restore our homeostatic capacity back to
like an 18 year old for a couple more
years can we actually you know there's
so much that we don't actually know
because it's just been such a long
period of time with so many different
evolutions that have occurred and so we
love thinking about like what from like
the palette of
evolution could we apply to longevity or
could we apply to to to just living
healthier and more fulfilling lives
I think sleep more don't drink alcohol
sometimes you have to come down to a
plant right I think that this is
something that it falls into the same
fallacies of Western thinking at some
time that there's a there's a treatment
you can take that'll fix everything but
I think sometimes what's missing is some
kind of holistic understanding of your
own human body and the people around you
so you know getting this is a simple
thing drinking water sleeping enough and
eating a proper diet that is you know
giving you the nutrients you need and
avoiding the things that you know
provide oxidative stress that make you
feel and look older I think you're
probably the big things and then you
know you can use plants to plants I
often think of as they can support
health so a lot of the you know plant
page drugs are actually things that are
somewhat mild in their effect but they
support well-being for some particular
Oregon or some condition and then there
is and those might be for William for
chronic conditions or something but then
there are acute medicines and for maybe
acute illnesses or something very
serious and that may be a really strong
or potent poison that is given at the
right dosage that treats something so I
worked with the Madagascar periwinkle
for many years which produces
vincristine I've been blasting there
used for cancer they stopped cell
division just like I was talking about
the caterpillar they see it's what you
might call an anti feed and so it stops
the caterpillar from eating but it also
stops and rapid cell division in a human
so that's an acute molecule that comes
from a poisonous plant that we use and
there are several examples of that did
you tell I started from foxglove is
something that if you just eat the plant
you might have a heart attack you know
it's not good for your heart but it's
used as a drug for people
that have that need their heart kind of
kick-started in some ways right yeah
we're not in the right dosage yeah we're
not different from our environment we
are our environment and when you view it
from a holistic perspective the
nutrition the sleep the exercise the
social environment when we're addicted
to the devices versus the love and
compassion and empathy and yeah an
emotion and social there so all these
things kind of tie in to that holistic
understanding of health and then yeah so
this is that that's a lot of you know
Aetna Bonnie on on kind of like a hue on
our human in many ways a human level I
like how you said economic botany is
that's an interesting way of seeing how
we actually move goods also it was cool
how we moved plants around the world it
was cool how you said that certain
populations of people still use the
baskets and the use the plants for their
houses the this type of thinking is like
plants are for like every part of their
lives I mean this table office this is
mo botany yeah yeah I mean we really
forget these things I think sometimes in
the culinary I mean so those are all
things that took a human growing it but
also email maybe thousands of years of
influence human plant influence to get
that type of cotton that is good for a
shirt or this would you know place where
it would be growing and then harvested
yes so we just forget these things
because it's not in front of us
especially if we're in a city we don't
realize how we entered it so so in the
class I teach a class on environmental
field work at Tufts and so the project
really could be whatever I wanted it to
be but the project we focus on is urban
forage yeah so that's like what plants
around us are actually edible or in or
medicinal
we talked about that as well yeah and
for the students I think like they'd
never thought about that and they have
some sort of like plant blindness it
might be called where everything just
looks green and they don't know is what
it's all grass or whatever time but when
I take them out and we look at things
and we start as you look closer and
closer as you zoom in you start to see
there's many different species of things
and then there's stories behind every
single one of those plants and they each
kind of present on different plants
throughout the semester and then they
catalog where all those are they find
out what this plant was brought from
Europe because people valued it for this
or this plant was brought from a part of
Asia because people used it for this and
that we can actually claim that power of
knowing what the plants are around us
and then even maybe even using them and
then maybe that changes how we do
landscaping or maybe it changes how we
live all together not worrying about the
weeds that go around us because they
actually had some kind of function in
our lives and they still can would you
would you walk around and if you if you
want to care more you can't like double
click into the greenery that is we here
we zoom in we pinch those who invention
if they have the greenery and then when
you actually go there like face to a
plant and then you look you know next to
it you see something different
yeah and you wonder where is that plan
from how long has it you know been in
this area how did it get here what is
its purpose here
does it have insects living in it what
nutrients does it mean how much sunlight
does it need all those questions start
to come for the student too because it's
a human thing right they start to be
curious about all that you know and as
part of that we also do soil testing
because you know there's at least 100
maybe more years of you know lead paint
and gas stations and dry cleaners and
have put stuff into the soil that can be
taken up into the plant so we do some of
that and that's part of the
environmental aspect of it as well but
that is the current state of ethnobotany
right I mean we don't live in this
pristine you know untouched Glade where
we can just pick anything and know that
it's good for us that's right it to be
retaught and we have to look at things a
little bit differently as well that's
right what a cool class to urban
foraging class that's just one of the
classes that people line up to take you
for my travel time cuz we want students
to be excited about this stuff right
yeah that's one at Tufts that's a tough
and then you you also teach another
class at Tufts called cannabis debate
yes so of course students line up to
take that course I think I had 100
emails from students who were pleading
to get into this course and I felt bad
we just didn't have the space Monday was
the last class I co teach that class and
my partner was an attorney I spelled
canis cannabis debate science culture in
the law so I focus on the science and
some of the culture and he takes some of
the culture in the wall but it really is
a part of the reason we call it cannabis
debate is because we wanted parents to
be okay with it being on the transcript
yeah if we just call it weed 101 school
but I'm a per the administration that
appreciated that and they fully have
supported it's awesome yeah so and there
is some debate like at times it doesn't
necessarily seem like for recreational
use of cannabis oh yeah hourly basis is
I mean conducive sometimes that sure I
do I mean yeah but that's a good friend
I mean that's right but the debate is
not like yes or no should we have
cannabis and no it's like the debates
over AG nuance in cannabis legalized
knows is here to stay yes yes so
prohibition has ended that we might
think of it in many ways
indeed and and and we will look back at
this period of prohibition kind of was
probably folly immediately especially
what the ramifications of the war on
drugs and things like that
Oh Harmons a natural plant evolves with
co-evolved with humans on earth and
we're just gonna ban it right right yeah
exactly yeah there's so much more nuance
to it's right it's great that the
students are getting to engage it yeah
and it's been really informative and I
mean people ask me why did you teach
this guys I mean it's not my area of
research or anything but
it actually is I mean it's a great
example of ethnobotany it's a great
example of human plant interaction and
how we have influenced a plant and the
plant has influenced us yes
and also I always think of cannabis as a
kind of Arrowhead the spearhead that
will get us to be able to speak fluently
about many other medicinal plants
cannabis isn't just THC and CBD it's
it's maybe house right I mean there's em
but you know there's just there's lots
of molecules doing lots of things nearby
and there's lots of different cultivated
varieties that are doing lots of
different things so that's the same
thing with any medicinal plant if you
look at gingko biloba or ginseng and you
were to buy 10 bottles of it from no
drug store you would have 10 different
chemical profiles likely because of the
environmental conditions under which it
was grown the age of the plant it would
all change and that's the same questions
were answering now with cannabis and and
we're grappling with the variability and
how do we test for these things and what
do we care about so if we can answer
those questions of the cannabis first I
think people may become more comfortable
and regulators may find better ways to
understand how we can use these plant
based medicines better yeah yeah that's
such a good class I'm so happy that one
and then there's also you were telling
me you were coming back I want to you I
want you to give this example because
it's kind of like a geopolitical example
like another part of the world you're
coming back from a conference in
Barbados and Barbados has a high amount
of sugar cane fields yeah and so teach
us about what an ethno botanist what
their lens is when they look at yeah
sure so I mean there's so much because
sugar cane came with slavery or slavery
came with sugar cane however you want to
look at it and also many other plants so
Barbados is it's an island unto itself
it had an endemic botany so it had lots
of its own plants the last assessment of
the botany of Barbados showed there were
just two endemic species left and the
rest were all foreign
were brought into the island actually
this untrue some of them were indigenous
plants but not endemic meaning they're
not unique to that place and then I
think most recently said that they can't
find the other one so there's only one
endemic species left in Barbados
of like 600 plant species or something
that are on the island and that is
because and I'm getting pretty specific
to Barbados but there are lessons here
so Barbados was not is not a volcanic
island it's a it's made of coral so it's
fairly flat so it's easy for for if she
was very flattened and cleared and then
put a whole bunch of sugarcane to fuel
rum trader and introvert and bring
slaves in to care for the sugarcane it
also brought other than other species
like breadfruit which was some people
say was brought as food for the Slayers
and other kind of tropical plants as
well but basically it's a monoculture of
sugarcane that's what the agriculture in
Barbados has been sugarcane and now the
shrimp pain is being supplemented by
government just to keep things going in
some way there are a few rum
distilleries still in Barbados that they
do that we so it was me and several
other ethnobotany so there we spoke
about many things but we wanted to you
know give some perspective about what
other types of agricultural endeavors
could be pursued in Barbados one idea
might even be cannabis right I mean if
there's gonna be a global cannabis trade
of some sort there's no reason why this
sugar cane fields can't be cannabis
fields grown for medicinal purposes or
for for CBD or whatever yeah so I mean
from an ethnic botanist point of view
it's about interfacing with anthropology
botany chemistry pharmacology those are
when I teach about medicinal plants
those are the four pillars of
understanding that I try to build that
knowledge on yeah yeah give us the four
pillars again it's a and this is for
medicinal plants anthropology botany
chemistry and pharmacology
and I so for instance a class I'm
teaching at Harvard on medicinal plants
you know that we present it in that
order and then we kind of culminate
things by going for a plant walk and
planting all those things yeah that's
great and this is at Harvard and at
Tufts yes yes men it's the medicinal
plants from the sacred to the scientific
and that's also the title of the book
that will hopefully be out by the end of
this year yes yeah yeah interesting what
else about them from the sacred to the
scientific with medicinal plant should
we know well and the reason I call it as
because you know some of the earliest
understandings that it may be well first
of all it covers a lot of interest for
people because some people are very
interested in the anthropological and
spiritual social aspects of how people
use plants and I feel like you can't
separate that from what we might think
of a science as things have a lot to
tell each other so I think it's really
about I mean part of this is about
someone like me who's a scientist who
studies these things seriously and
academically I you mentioned I mean I'm
a researcher at Harvard I'm a researcher
at MIT I do things on this one level but
then saying I'm willing to talk about
herbal medicine and I'm willing to talk
about the spiritual side of how people
have chosen reliance because I know that
those things should shouldn't be
separated and that there's value to them
like I said the majority of things that
we use as medicine come from nature in
some way are inspired by nature so yeah
for me it's about into integrated
medicine it's integrating human health
spirituality social aspect as you
mentioned that's part of health and
making people feel more whole in some
way and allowing people to reclaim that
so I did I mention that I just visited
an herbal practitioner in an upstate New
York her name is Susan weed who I honor
every time I teach I always mention her
she's sometimes calls herself a green
witch she practices herbal medicine and
she's a great teacher and what part of
what she teaches that herbal medicine is
people's medicine and I repeat that to
my students and let them think about
what that actually means I mean in some
ways it means it should be and can be
accessible to most people people don't
need to rely on a man in a white coat
giving a isolated compound in a white
pill there are ways to use the plants
around us as medicine humans have
figured it out for a long time and
although some societies my arguable and
that's the ideal way to do it
the truth is right now we're just not in
a state where everyone can have access
to those things and we we work towards
that towards having the best medicine
for everyone but there are also ways to
learn from those complex plant medicines
that could still be good for people yeah
yeah yeah there's a it's all under the
umbrella of sacred scientific it's all
under an umbrella of coevolution of
humans with plants yeah yeah is is the
the biotech that you're teaching at
Northeastern yeah what's a good example
of some of the midcourt material from
that yeah so this class it's an
introduction about our technology and
biotechnology for most people nowadays
especially in the Cambridge Boston area
means working with protein drugs or
large molecule pharmaceuticals and a lot
of these are actually for treating what
I some has called diseases of the
affluent so things like cancer and other
things that people live old enough to
get and at high numbers whereas you know
in other parts of the world people might
be dying of infections and things
much younger ages so any and other
reason its affluence is tied to this
because these drugs are incredibly
expensive and incredibly again
labor-intensive to produce these drugs
so in that class traces the pathway of
the biotechnological pipeline from drug
manufacturing side of things it doesn't
really get into plant based medicine
because this is mostly has to do with
genetically engineering let's say animal
cells to produce a specific antibody
drug or protein that will then treat
some particular disease but as part of
that now I've just put together a
syllabus for an agricultural
biotechnology course which will cover
all the ways that biotech potentially
has been used and can be used to change
a grigory I mean everything that people
may have heard of Golden Rice which was
one of the first genetically modified
plant organisms that allowed humans to
have access to nutrients that they
wouldn't have had otherwise children
were going blind from lack of nutrition
and you know something like this is a
way to you know so I mean there are a
lot of people anti GMO right broadly and
even in entire countries for anti GMO
but what they probably are actually an
tyre anti the business practices that
are behind some of the work that's a big
done with genetically modified organisms
because in plant biotech but humans have
been doing some sort of a sort of
biotechnology in that they're
manipulating the plant genome and some
way for thousands of years people have
been crossing plants and creating things
so human hands have had absolutely an
influence the cannabis plant did not get
the way it is without human influence
the apples you eat are not they may not
be GMO and the biotech sense but they
were human or engineered things just
like corn or wheat or any of these
things were completely modified by human
intervention we kept wanting
pair for the genetics that we wanted
right yeah yes and then crossing things
and making mutants of things and until
we got what we wanted and you know the
future of that is it has to be done
properly of course but there's great
potential for feeding and as I started
this whole thing with the idea of over
populating the world if the world is
going to continue to grow in population
we have to find new ways that we can be
innovative to feed the world
unfortunately that's just the way it is
it may include genetically modifying
crop them so that they're less disease
they're more disease resistant so their
yields are higher I mean that's kind of
where we've gotten ourselves for better
or worse genetically modified organisms
in some way are here to stay and we and
if we're going to use them we need to
use them to solve these big problems
like I kind of started talking about
yeah I think it was really fascinating
when you said that the diseases of the
affluent are the ones when you live long
enough to be able to get the cancers
that shows like viagra right I mean
that's not an essential drug for the
world necessarily but a lot of money
time scientific expertise has been spent
on that yeah I mean it's not to discount
the research and a cancer drug Louie
that is just that there if we were to
actually kind of have a level playing
four we looked at things like neglected
tropical diseases that's right you know
we would have a more fair way of looking
at somebody we want we want to target
the basic physiological needs that are
not being met in the world and then go
and alleviate that those ailments that
come from that and then enable the full
creative development of people and then
also tackle cancer and dementia
they're big things at the same time and
another one of the things that you said
was just that with in biotechnology and
it's so good that you're teaching about
it that there is you know we work so
much with Indy bio and I mentor their to
the largest seed stage biotech
accelerator and what they're working on
her everything especially food wise like
like growing meat without the animals
all right yeah it's such a fascinating
space and that I think we're gonna be
able to sustainably feed the world by
leveraging the tools that biotechnology
can inspire young people to get involved
with it you also do this a bit at MIT
Media Lab the open agriculture
initiative is fascinating the food
computer I saw the video of the food
computer I'm gonna embed that video here
for everyone to see but you do so much
so many sensors their co2 sensor
temperature sensor humidity sensor and
light panels was a new brain and a new
interface and a cloud back-end you can
add sensors for pH and water temperature
electrical conductivity extra cameras I
thought this was so cool scene it looks
like a little MakerBot on a bowl and you
can grow plants within it and actually
all the science that's happening yeah so
now we now we can go really strange
because all the things I've talked about
have been about what you might think of
like indigenous medicine indigenous
people and but I think that the
uniqueness that I try to bring is you
know of course that no botanist have
studied indigenous people in fact here
at Harvard the person who kind of Populi
the body the most as Richard Shelties
and I had I'm lucky enough to be working
exactly where he were as a young person
I never thought I'd have that chance but
now at the Harvard herbarium is exactly
where he was working studying these
indigenous people and in some ways
they're technologies right we may not
call it technology the way we think of
the technology but humans develop
technology to interface with the world
particularly when it comes to plants so
that's what by ethnobotany meant
for me part of my mission has been to
redefine what ethnobotany means and
that's why I've been so lucky to work at
the Media Lab which is really like the
Harry Potter's magic studio of making
magic things with so many amazing
programs there I gave a talk about a
year ago the director of open
agriculture at the Media Lab Caleb
Harper was at the same conference and he
invited me to come visit the laboratory
which is out at the Bates laboratory at
MIT which is actually like 40 minutes
north of Boston at the old it's a
retired linear particle accelerator pre
CERN days and fascinating place spooky
tunnels everywhere filled with kind of
old technologies but they gave us a
warehouse where we put in large shipping
containers that we've converted into
controlled growing environments little
bit so that's what we do out there so to
me this is the new idea of what
ethnobotany can be so if looking at
where people are now and how they
interface with plants and what the
future of that can be so at open
agriculture one of our specialties is
looking at controlled environment
growing systems yes and we have what's
called the food computer which is a 30
centimeter by 30 centimeter unit that's
completely scalable there's actually
food computers a general term for all
the types of computers that we build
that interface with our food or plants
in any way so a lot I love that pairing
of the words yeah computer right yeah
yeah so yeah and this tool so this 30
cinnamon read-through sumit centimetre
box which is our is those dimensions
because of a NASA challenge they wanted
something that was the size like a
documentation yeah so that's why we made
it that size this is the third iteration
and there will be a fourth and fifth
already in the works for this the
mission for us was to make a small unit
that could actually be used for stem and
steam education yeah so this is
something that we put into middle
schools and high schools it's in 65
countries around the world
and it's cheap to make everything can be
fabricated pretty easily all from the
same material for cheap parts you can
buy pretty easily and then it's a this
mini controlled environment that allows
you to grow something we our specialty
has been basil it's kind of like our lab
rat for Holi we're doing so we grow
basil on these small containers and and
we teach kids about plants so some of
these kids don't know that a tomato
comes from the ground and a plant they
think it just comes from a grocery store
right they don't understand that
connection right but I mean that really
happens they don't know that we get oh
my god we're so deep in metropolis is
that sometimes yeah the kids not only
don't see stars they don't know the food
comes from the farm right exactly so if
kids don't know that then what kind of
like environmental stewards are gonna be
like they're gonna care about who they
vote for or anything if they don't even
understand the simple process or even if
they have a vague understanding they
don't have a tactile understanding
they're not you I you know for years my
partner and I had put together a school
gardens and community gardens he was on
the school board and the town that we
lived in and we would work to encourage
that to happen and what we saw our kids
for the first time interfacing the
plants they learn a new speed of time
time passes differently they have a new
understanding for patience yeah so all
those things happen and when you have
these little units they same idea you
know they they have to watch this thing
grow they see things go wrong or right
and also while they're doing this all
the variables that they're changing and
all the sensors that you mentioned are
uploading that data to the cloud and in
forming what's called a climate recipe
and then we can learn we use machine
learning to learn from all these
different iterations of how the plant
grew it's always say it takes images as
well of the plant that's all so we use
that to build a system machine learning
system yeah so that same tool the food
computer which is the
it's called a PFC edu personal food
computer education for educational
purposes so that's the personal food
computer using that same technology
scaled up we built the food server so
this is a shipping container sized
version we publish a paper earlier this
month in April thinking of food for
communities yeah exactly so what we at
the Media Lab it's a unique funding
system where companies become members
and then they give us some sort of
challenge and I could fund particular
projects so actually target wanted to
grow plants things like basil or herbs
or high-value products close to the
store so they don't have to ship them
but this same idea we've actually
implemented in other places so we've
partnered with a well spun the company
cotton company in India and we've
actually put these container we've gone
to India and installed these help them
install these units where they can grow
a specialty cotton inside these units
and learn about the environment and
these tools are used not just for
production so you might be thinking okay
how much can I grow in this thing and
how I can't grow an apple in them right
because it's kind of not built for that
but you can use this tool to not just
for production but you can also use it
as an experimental platform so it allows
you to isolate specific variables so if
you wanted to know what happens when an
insect is on this plant or what happens
when I change the pH or if I change the
temperature then it will give you some
information about the plants that you're
growing themselves in fact it could help
you choose which cultivated variety of
the plant you're going to put out in the
field we recently built what we call the
tree computer so we work with Ferrero
who's the maker of Nutella and for Roche
so it's a confectioner but think about
how many other practical implications
this might have they said you know we
grow most of the hazelnuts in the world
which is what they use for Nutella are
grown in Turkey which doesn't have a
perfectly stable a governmental
situation it doesn't
there's problems with pests coming in
and they wanted to diversify in other
parts of the world so they said can you
build us one of these computers that we
could put a tree inside and then figure
out what climate might be best to grow a
variety so we did that we built this
tree computer we put them in there and
then we test extremes like extreme cold
extreme heat of targeted environments
around the world and then we could tell
them okay you want to grow in Adelaide
Australia we punch in the environment
all extremes then we see okay
eight of these cultivars will never live
there and two of them would do okay so
then that saves them a lot of time and
money and says okay we'll promote these
two cultivated varieties and we'll grow
them there and the same thing could
happen that helps us make more food
right it helps us have a better world in
general because we're not wasting time
and money and effort you're running all
of the permutations of the possibilities
of where plants can most effectively
grow around the world way faster than an
organization could you gave the example
of an unstable potentially country where
majority of the plant is grown or
another one is when you drop an insect
into the personal food computers and you
can literally watch the variables change
and how that insect is affecting it that
that is so cool and I 65 countries
around the world now with these
scalability you can take it from 30 30
centimeters all the way up to and people
are riffing on them because we
everything's oh it's open agriculture so
we don't keep anything secret it's an
open even worse initiative yeah so
that's the real key here because even
though we have to partner with Target
and Ferraro and these other companies
because that's the model of the Media
Lab they have to agree to make
everything open to the public so
typically as controlled environments are
incredibly privately held the technology
is clustered and you never hear about is
harder for would want to keep it for
themselves and then maybe distribute
their patent to other companies and make
money but in this case you're doing it
as an open learning initiative and
that's so cool because then other
around the world can pick up the shoe
the big shipping containers and like you
said be growing for there and there may
be a question like well this seems very
expensive and you know how would people
in developing parts of the world
participate in this what the vision is
that well the technologies are being
developed we want as many people who can
be a part of it be a part of it and what
we want people is to be a part of the
destiny not subject to it or a part of
the development of the technology not
subject to the technology that's
delivered to them so that's why we have
that we have online community that you
know we hear from them they ask
questions and it's very participatory so
the idea is you know open source and
open knowledge and having people share
and improve on that knowledge yeah you
get to the edge you make a massive new
open source advancement and then that
does not keep it you know closed off it
pushes the edge further faster and then
teach us about the flavor cyber
agriculture as well reducing waste
meeting demand maintaining flavor
providing nutrition yeah yeah so a
flavor cyber X a cyber AG is kind of a
term for these types of devices and what
we're doing here cyber just being like
computerized agriculture in some way
this flavor cyber agriculture was the
name of the paper that we just published
about a month ago that showed that we
could modulate we could tune the flavor
of basil in some way just by modulating
in this case we were doing light UV
light and different times of exposure to
that light
but the bigger picture of this is is the
tune ability of a plant in some ways so
this idea that indigenous people
understood this for thousands of years
that you pick a plant on this side of
the mountain at this time of day with
this weather because it gives you this
product we can now iterate an experiment
on in a cyber agriculture unit and we
could say okay what do we need to do to
tune this let's say we wanted to make a
medicinal plant let's say we wanted to
make
an anti diabetes basil because we grow a
lot of basil what do want to do to
change that plant so that it produces
most of that chemical that will be anti
diabetic or people around the world you
can't get insulin or metformin or some
other anti diabetes medication that's
some of the work I did in my previous
research before I came here and it's
some of the work we're continue to do
now at MIT it's so fast they being able
to tweak this age of cyber agriculture
the different variables and be able to
produce different of medicines and
flavors and all this cool that's so
interesting what is the future of
ethnobotany I think we're defining it I
think that so ethnobotany you know in
the 40s 50s 60s people were very
interested in how can we discover drugs
from plants that are in parts of the
world we haven't discovered so f no
botanist had a real value to big
companies for going out and discovering
and identifying all these plants again
like I said a lot of that work was done
by Richard Shelties and his students at
Harvard now then it kind of dissipated a
bit I would say because drug companies
became not as interested they weren't
finding as many leads from nature that
they used to it was very labor-intensive
and then now we've we've been a bit I
would say for the past maybe 15 20 years
we've been trying to define what the
future is I mean I'm trying to do that
with my fellow ethno botanist published
a paper two years ago called ethno phyto
technology so that's taking ethnobotany
and biotechnology and smashing them
together because really that is
ethnobotany is a science of studying
plants and people biotechnology is a
people driven
but people-driven science that relies on
nature in some way so it's just natural
that we we do plant biotechnology right
but what have we incorporated the human
aspect even more what have we
incorporated the ethnobotanical
understanding of how people have used
these plants or even just the notion
that humans have understood that
environment changes plant chemistry and
then start to utilize that knowledge and
pipelines to discover new things or make
things better from the plant perspective
that I think the future is integrating
these things all the way from biotech to
artificial intelligence I mentioned
machine learning all these all these
iterations of experiments we do all the
data because there's so much data all
those sensors it's like an Internet of
Things idea right so we give a talk on
the Internet of food not too long ago
because now we have all these sensors
uploading all this data how do we
utilize that iof yeah yeah so we the way
that we use is we put it into machine
learning models and we that's the entire
paper that was published was based on we
worked with a company called cognizant
which has I think 280,000 employees
around the world who has an interest in
modeling things and they use you know
the most modern techniques and
artificial toes and machine learning in
order to give us these outcomes so I
think the future is just recognizing
where humans are now using that honoring
and utilizing some that indigenous
knowledge and then making sure we're
sharing that around the world so that's
one aspect it's beautiful race it has to
be shared back to the whole world so
we're going all the way from sacred and
indigenous plant medicines to the
Internet of food the food computers the
machine learning algorithms that we have
now and we're open sourcing right that
wisdoms were providing an open sourcing
I love that because the history of the
world has been stealing from people who
were weaker and then using it
the people who though Victor's right but
we're trying to reverse that in some way
if we can take some of this knowledge
improve upon it and have it be open
source for everyone to use I think
that's a better model for living even in
the world that keeps growing in
population where food and plants are
going to be vital to our survival I
think it's the best way for and what a
beautiful thing to have the companies
like Target or a Walmart or an Amazon or
an apple the largest companies in the
world across the world even in China and
whatnot to be open sourcing the
technology that they're working with
cool institutions like a Media Lab so
that they get access to it immediately
because they funded it as well but then
it's democratized as well right away I
love that process so much I think that's
kind of like open notebook science at
the edge of knowledge and that's I think
that's a lot of our future two quick
questions on the way out that we like
asking our guests first question is John
do you think we're in a simulation yes
absolutely
that's my that's my maybe people won't
have watched all the way to the end of
the what is a simulation rate
artificial intelligence someone asked me
what is artificial house and I said it's
in its intelligence right because we're
recreating that now I absolutely open to
the possibility that we're in a
simulation yeah I think in fact like to
my mind sometimes it makes the most
sense especially for the you know even
listen listening to my story there have
been so many times where things have
been too bizarre to explain yeah so that
was a part of RoboForm
to Manhattan right right but also all
the little things you don't mention that
the repetitions that happen the cues
that you see yes those are things that
people have attributed to spirituality
and God and other things so just as
bizarre is a simulation so I put that up
there with explaining the unexplained I
think that we should not be so arrogant
I think that we have it all figured out
on this little tiny speck of dust
floating in space I mean that that's
really how I guess that's essentially
how I feel I'm open
if I weren't open to bizarre crazy ideas
I wouldn't be doing the things I'm doing
so I think of course we could be in a
simulation yeah there's there's also the
what we'll learn as we in the next
couple of decades hopefully run our own
simulations and be able to analyze the
way that the humans evolved and you're
right the attribution of - what happened
pretty big bang why are we here right
all that all these have interesting
questions all right and the last
question is what is the most beautiful
thing in the world the most beautiful
thing in the world I should have watched
your other second domain it's better I
don't you know I was like I can't know
the name for it but hey hey yeah have
you heard of this term the like
Norwegian term or something for this
kind of centered peacefulness that comes
from being around people that you love
and they love you and they understand
you I think that even if you're in like
a cabin and it's dark outside and cold
you can have some comfort because you're
around people
understand you in some way so I think
that people are always trying to get
their people I think a lot of humans are
always trying to get to a comfortable
place where they feel useful but also
know that people understand what they
are I think that feeling is probably the
most beautiful thing in the world
because it's so unique because a lot of
the things around us are relatively
inert but it's almost like the highest
form of evolution or something right
like the ability to that incorporates
love and peace and all those other
things but then feeling useful and
feeling loved and feeling like you can
communicate with someone I think that
that that can be the most most beautiful
thing in the world
oh yeah that's well oh yeah yeah it's
one of the deepest human feelings right
yeah yeah and every human deserves to
have that absolutely that's a way yeah
when the simulation is doing a really
good job yeah that's right what we have
that feeling when we put the new code
deployments the updates and humans can
have that feeling of all the basic
physiological needs but so right if we
could encapsulate that feeling and say
okay like I haven't I felt this and now
I know that everyone in the world should
have the ability to feel this then then
that just expands all the beauty that's
right yeah yeah
John della paura what an absolute
pleasure thank you so much for the show
yeah this is such a pleasure so
enlightening thank you for teaching us
about ethnobotany
and about the craziness of food
computers and the cannabis debate course
all this kind of stuff so fasting we're
excited to continue on building
relationship and making connections for
each other you're welcome of course any
time back
join us on the show again we'd love to
do that thanks everyone for tuning in we
greatly appreciate we'd love to hear
your thoughts in the comments below on
the episode go and share more
conversations about that no Bonnie
everything from the sacred and the
indigenous all the way to the new
internet of food era should your friends
your families your co-workers online go
and start talking about it more and
inspiring more people to build the
future in this regard check out John's
links below as well go and support him
also support the artist entrepreneurs
and organizations around the world that
you believe in support simulation our
links are below so you continue doing
cool things like coming to the Boston
area and interview people like John and
go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world
thank you so much for tuning in and we
will see you soon